today on the matt walsh show aoc and
others on the left have been celebrating
the glories of
sex work and defending sites like only
fans this week
they say it's a legitimate and noble way
to make a living
why are leftists always encouraging
people to do things that make them
miserable we'll talk about that also
five headlines including
six hundred dollar stimulus checks as
part of the latest covid relief bill
what good will six hundred dollars do
and today in our daily cancellation
we'll cancel uh or rather we will
discuss and cancel lots of people
associated with the intense controversy
over the singer lizzo
drinking a smoothie is she betraying the
fat community
we'll deal with that question and more
today on the matt wells show
you know something to think about as we
head into the new year maybe sort of a
new year's resolution
is uh that we all should should uh
should
consider is supporting
companies that support us in the culture
companies because there's a lot of there
are a lot of companies that we don't we
have a lot of money to that to them
sort of inevitably but when we find a
company that supports our values we
should support them
and uh that should begin with the
pro-life phone company charity mobile
like with charity mobile five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life
pro family charity of your choice and
that's the that's the charity part of it
and it's great there's also a lot of
great benefits
it's just it's a great service in
general new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's also no risk so
you can try them out you get a 30-day
guarantee but you're going to love
you're going to love the service you're
going to love
also the fact that there's live customer
service based in the usa if you ever
need help
and look you can you can block the use
of cellular data picture messages text
messages
messages on any of of the lines on your
account
you get free usage alerts you get a free
app to monitor
your usage and pay your bill makes it
very convenient
and while doing all that and taking
advantage of this service you're also
helping to build a culture of life
in america by supporting a pro-life
phone company
so i would urge you to call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
this week the new york post has come in
for intense criticism after publishing
an article about a paramedic in the city
who was working a side job
selling pornographic images of herself
on the website only fans
the emt worker lauren quay apparently
didn't want to be profiled by the paper
but they published a story anyway
now it's not true that the post doxed
quay as they've been accused by other
media publications doxxing is the
malicious publication of private
information
the story may have been malicious but
they were publishing what the woman
herself had already
publicly revealed you know anything you
put on the internet for public
consumption
is no longer private by definition the
new york post did not
force quay or any other woman to make
public what should be private that was
her decision
now with that said the story was
inappropriate and rather
baffling as qui is not a public figure
and nothing about her life is newsworthy
lots of people put embarrassing material
on the internet on purpose
a news organization should have a clear
and ethical reason for publishing
that material i can't imagine what that
reason would be in this case
but the national conversation has gone
beyond merely criticizing
rightly i think the post for running a
needless and oddly vindictive story
about a random woman on only fans
quickly
the controversy became an opportunity
for prominent voices on the left
to promote sex work itself as a
legitimate pursuit representative
alexandria caser cortez
along with the aclu and others have
declared this week that
sex work is work lengthy think pieces
have been written
defending cyber prostitution and
old-fashioned prostitution too has noble
professions
now while the wagons are circled around
only fans other publications like the
the daily beast have uh this week
worried that the recent criticism of
pornhub
may be driven by anti-sex work bias
which is a very bad thing it's long been
a goal of the left to
normalize prostitution companies like
pornhub and especially only fans porn
sites that
empower women by providing them a
platform to sell their bodies
have essentially achieved that
long-sought goal of normalizing
prostitution
even while prostitution remains
technically illegal in most states in
the union
but is it true though are women
empowered
through prostituting themselves online
or offline
is sex work real work as
aoc contends now as to the latter
question in a very strict
dictionary sense the answer is yes work
means
it's defined as activity involving
mental or physical effort done in order
to achieve
a purpose or result so i suppose there's
a very
minimal amount of physical effort
involved in posing nude for a webcam
and the intended result of helping men
masturbate in exchange for profit
is no doubt accomplished but if we take
a more elevated view of work
and we define it as the use of a certain
skill
in performing crucial services that have
tangible and lasting benefit to the
consumer
it is not work at all there is no skill
involved in taking off your clothes
and there's no lasting benefit to the
other person involved in the transaction
now perhaps you could say my definition
of work is a bit ad hoc
you know i came up with it in order to
disqualify prostitution
maybe so but it points to the clear
distinction
that obviously exists between a
prostitute and say a car mechanic
both are doing something with their
bodies in exchange for money fine
but only one involves a tangible and
rare skill
and the results will benefit the
consumer in a substantial way
and for longer than a few moments if
these are both
work or even real work
they're still not the same kind of work
there's a reason one is respected and
the other is not
and it ought to stay that way
the other thing that separates the only
fans prostitutes from members of more
dignified professions
is that the prostitute debases and
dehumanizes herself
her entire role is to be debased and
dehumanized
she is meant to be nothing but a
masturbatory aid an empty vessel
faceless and nameless workers and other
kinds of jobs may
feel rather debased at times and often
for good reason
but the prostitute offers up her
debasement as the product
her body her privacy her sexuality all
that is most intimate and sacred
is what she sells it's a very different
sort of thing from the walmart cashier
who may experience her own sort of
namelessness but
her dignity is not the product that
consumers have come to buy
there's a reason that drug abuse and
suicide are so common among porn stars
and prostitutes
the media chalks it up to mental illness
or
social ostracization but one need not be
sick
or alienated to feel despair amid a life
dedicated to one's own degradation
of course women are depressed when their
quote work
consists of presenting their bodies to
be oggled by creepy men on the internet
what else would they feel joy
fulfillment you know we're constantly
being assured
by miserable people that if we do what
is meaningless and empty
we're gonna find happiness as always the
lie reveals itself
nobody actually is happy doing these
things that are supposed to make them
happy
we find despair and self-destruction
where the happiness was supposed to be
that's how it always goes but it was
interesting to debate
this issue on twitter this week and read
the counter arguments
as i have been doing two themes emerge
both seeming at first to contradict the
other you know first i was told
as we discussed that prostitution and
porn are empowering and beautiful
but second i've also been told over and
over again
that all work is debasing and
dehumanizing
every worker is a prostitute in effect
because
they're being exploited in exchange for
money now this is marxism and it's wrong
but it helps clarify what's really
happening here
see it it turns out that the left is not
actually elevating prostitution by
calling it real work
they are rather degrading real work
they aren't trying to pull prostitution
up to the level of work
what they're doing is pulling work down
to the level of prostitution
yes prostitution is dehumanizing
exploitative and ultimately pointless
but so is everything else they say their
view of life of everything
is so vulgar and dreary that they cannot
see the difference between
somebody who uses skills and talents
they've cultivated in order to provide a
good or service that has actual value
and makes people's lives better
and someone taking off their clothes and
showing their genitals to strangers on
the internet
see it's not actually it turns out that
they see the genital flasher as doing
something noble it's that they can't
understand
why the person with the real job is
doing something noble
they don't know what noble is or what it
means
they see the whole world in shades of
gray
and all things to them are empty at
their core
so why not prostitute yourself why not
turn your body into a commodity
why not treat it like something no more
valuable than a toaster oven you find in
the clearance section at walmart
nothing has value nothing has meaning
that's their fundamental belief
happily though life is
much more than they make it out to be
your body is much more
than a product that can be put on a
shelf your sexuality is much more than
a service to be bought and sold and that
is the actual truth
which is far more empowering far more
uplifting
far more liberating than anything these
people are telling us
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i think we can all agree that nobody
wants acne right that's not anything
there might be a few weirdos out there
but i think the vast majority of the
human race
don't want acne uh and that's why but
what people people get it's very common
condition and that's why you need
proactive proactive combines
gentle skin care paired with the best
acne treatment for your skin
proactive has three different systems
designed for your skin type and
because not everyone's skin is the same
and with proactive
there it's it's whatever you whatever
your personal needs are
they're able to meet it no matter your
type of breakdown breakout proactive
combines gentle skin care paired with
the best acne treatment
for you they've got three systems
okay they've got the proactive md
advanced which is prescription strength
for really stubborn breakouts they've
got proactive
plus gentle which is for more gentle
sensitive skin types
and then proactive solution original
which is the original
system and this is for for all types so
whatever you need if you need the more
heavy duty stuff you've got that if you
need something if you've got more
sensitive skin
you've got that too they've got
clinically
proven ingredients which are tested by
dermatologists we know this stuff
works it's really as simple as that
proactive works right now is a great
time to try proactive for my podcast
listeners
you can get a special offer available by
going to proactive.com
walsh proactive subscribers will receive
the hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four um hydrogel masks
and the green tea moisturizer you get
all of that
as a gift and good thing to have for the
holidays
you also get free shipping on top of
that again visit proactive.com
walsh to take advantage of this special
offer now that's proactive.com
walsh and subscribe to clear skin
report here from cbs it says lawmakers
are running out of time to pass another
coronavirus relief package before
congress adjourns for the holidays
a major point of contention is whether
any package will include a second round
of stimulus checks the direct cash
payments that help millions of
households whether the economic crunch
caused by the corn virus pandemic
of course to clarify this is not an
economic crunch
caused by the pandemic it's an economic
crunch caused by the disastrous
lockdowns where we're telling people
they can't go to work
um a uh a 908 billion dollar bipartisan
proposal initially left out stimulus
payments
um but a last-minute addition to the
package could include another round of
checks
most likely at the 600 per person level
um and so that's that's what we're
looking at right now it's not it's not
hasn't gone all the way through yet but
we're looking at six hundred dollars
a person and not for everybody you know
a lot of people aren't gonna get
anything
but this to me is is
just perfect this is this is a perfect
encapsulation
of uh of what we get from the government
and from lawmakers in that it's the
worst of all worlds
it's pretty much the worst possible
thing you could do to give
everybody 600 or give millions of people
600
because you're still spending all that
money okay we're still spending
billions and billions almost a trillion
dollars on top of the trillions we've
already spent
so we're still spending that we got that
part of it
but you're not giving nearly enough to
make any difference to anyone
you know either someone's in a position
where they're doing okay
and they and you know they might not be
thriving maybe they are thriving but
they're doing okay they're making it by
and for them sure six hundred dollars is
nice
but they don't really need it because
they're already they're they're not in
the middle of an economic crisis
um or someone is in a financial crisis
and you know is in is in debt dire
straits
and for them 600 is going to do almost
nothing
it'll pay a couple of bills but it's
that's it
i mean is there anyone in america who
right now
is in a situation where
they're they're in a crisis but all they
need is six hundred dollars
maybe someone who who who borrowed some
money from the mob
or has gambling debts and needs 600
bucks but
i think the people who are in a crisis
because of these
lockdowns need a lot more than 600.
so you get people who who don't need
anything who are given we're going to be
paying billions of dollars to give money
to
a lot of people who don't need anything
and also billions to give
uh not enough money to people who need a
lot more
so there's no point either give nothing
to anybody
or you need to give a lot more than this
um all right let's go number two
abc news has this we'll play the video
for you uh
it says cheers erupted in the streets of
buenos aires
argentina after the country's lower
house voted to pass a bill
legalizing abortion uh a measure that
will next go through the senate so you
can see here
the the crowds celebrating
uh celebrating the the passage of this
this bill
just
[Music]
you see they're jumping mostly women
younger women in the crowd
they're jumping they're hugging they're
waving flags
they're in tears they're crying tears of
joy
and what are they now you see something
like this and you think
if you had no context what would you
think is going on here
maybe maybe there's you know
you can see this maybe if they're
watching their team won the super bowl
something like that but no this is this
is they're excited
this is what they're excited about
they're excited they'll have the
opportunity now to kill their babies
they're in tears of joy
because now if they need to if they want
to they can kill their children
that's what they're weeping tears of joy
over
not you know no great shock here we know
that this is the case with the
pro-abortion movement
except that what are we always told
we're always told that the pro-abortion
movement
is not the pro-abortion movement they're
not oh nobody's nobody's pro-abortion
nobody
likes abortion this is the line we get
from per-abortion people
all the time no no one likes support no
one no one likes it no one's
oh we're pro-choice not pro-abortion
really that's what you just saw there
those aren't people who
who like abortion
there are in tears of joy hugging in the
street
because they can now kill their children
they obviously want to be able to do
that
they are very pro that
now the pro-abortion movement is is
starting
to move a little bit away from that line
of saying
you still hear it a lot but they're
starting there's a movement now
uh very clearly to move away from that
and to stop saying oh no one's
pro-abortion and instead to say sure
but this is still among mostly among the
radicals on the pro-abortion side who
will come out and you know shout your
abortion they say yeah you know i like
abortion
i'm in favor of abortion it's not yet in
the mainstream of the pro-abortion
movement but i think it will go there
and really it's their only it's it's
it's a
it's their only strategy because the
problem all along it's like when they
used to say
you never hear this anymore but i can
remember even growing up in the 90s
um the big the the line the the slogan
the thing they put on the poster boards
and the bumper stickers was um
safe legal and rare and now they yeah
they still want abortion to be
legal of course and they still talk
about the mythical safe abortion
which of course no abortion could be
safe because there's always at least one
person being killed in it
um and often more than one person being
well in fact in every case more than one
person being harmed
physically and emotionally in every
other sense but um
so but they still they still pretend so
they still say yeah safe legal
they don't talk about rare anymore
and the problem is when you say oh we
want abortion to be rare or when you say
oh
nobody really likes abortion the
follow-up question is why
well you say nobody likes it why don't
they like it
you say you want it to be rare why do
you want it to be rare
and the answer is because it's a it's a
it's a horrifying
horrible abominable thing
but if you admit that about abortion
then the whole house of cards comes
tumbling down
and so their only choice is to uh is to
pretend that it's
it's uh that in fact it's a positive
it's a it's something to celebrate
all right we played for you yesterday
the clip of tom cruise
berating the staff on the set of the new
mission impossible film
and now a number of celebrities have
come out to defend cruz
including george clooney who says that
he understands why cruz did what he did
um the guy who played olaf what was his
name
he he he he defended him whoopi goldberg
a bunch of celebrities have come out
and said that you know they've taken his
side this is weird for me because
i have no affinity for any of these
people tom cruise included
and i disagree with why they're saying
what they're saying
the people defend the celebrities
defending tom cruise they're defending
him on the basis that
you know everybody should be wearing
masks in fact in fact george clooney
said it in
in this answer i think he was on with
howard stern and he also said oh just
wear the damn mask
you know that's his point that yeah it's
good it's good that tom cruise is
yelling at people for not wearing masks
sort of in general i disagree with that
but i also have no problem as i said
yesterday i have no problem with what
tom cruise did and i read you know it
says also that five staffers
quit have already quit because of this
rant from cruz
and i'm more on cruz's side than the
staffers only because
if you if you go back and you listen to
what tom cruise was saying
he wasn't saying oh put the mask on
because you're going to kill me if you
don't you know you're
you're endangering my safety if you
don't if you don't wear the mask or if
you don't follow the protocols that
wasn't his point at all
his point was this is what we have to do
in order to keep this industry running
in order for people to have jobs and you
guys need to play this game
because this people depend on this and
this and they're going to lose their
homes and they're not going to be able
to feed their kids
if this movie gets shut down because you
guys can't follow the protocols that
we're all following
that i completely sympathize with
which is also why you know i've
the masking thing i hate
but i understand why businesses do it
because they have to do it in order to
open in order to stay open
at least many of them it kind of depends
on where they are what state they're in
what the local ordinances are how strict
it is but um
yeah i have a lot of respect for the
businesses that have taken a stand and
said no we're not going to go along with
it
but i also understand if you're a
business owner and you say look
you know i got to stay open i've got
employees i got to take care of
i can't afford to get a 5 000 fine every
day
that's going to shut us down and we're
all going to be homeless and i got a
responsibility to my employees so i got
to do this
i don't want to but i have to i
understand that too i'm sympathetic with
that
and that's why i say all of our anger
should be directed at at
the the government that the the tyrants
are imposing this stuff
not really at the business owners who
are just doing what they have to do to
navigate this and survive
um all right an espn commentator and
former nfl player has
made an admission that he probably
should have kept to himself
uh about why he doesn't like the buffalo
bills now plenty of good reasons not to
like the buffalo bills but um here's the
reason he came up with an
interview on a podcast this is um this
is i believe dominique foxworth
and here's what he said i would be 100
lying if i said that when josh does
something dumb
a little part of me doesn't get happy it
is not because i want josh to succeed
it's because the people who are telling
me that josh
is the second coming and josh is better
than everybody
are people with american flags and dogs
and skull and crossbones
in their eyes and then if you go just
take a dip
into their tweet history it's some
really
concerning retweets and likes
yeah um so that's josh allen the
quarterback of the buffalo bills is
referring to there
now just to be clear about what what
he's actually saying here uh and it's
it's not it's not very subtle
what he's basically saying is a lot of
white people like the buff
the buffalo bills and that's why i root
against them
that's what's right and well more
specifically white like conservative
people
people people with american flags um
for their profile pictures uh like the
buffalo bill so that's why i root
against them
there's just just some more more open
bigotry
just put out there no problem he's
gotten a little bit of pushback about
this
but but not much uh and he's fine
he'll keep his job on espn and because
this is the way it goes this is a
totally acceptable bigotry
in the united states today um okay
number five this is from npr
this is this is the the the headline
from npr they said pete budage
president-elect biden's pick for
transportation secretary
said that he has a personal love of
transportation recounting train trips on
amtrak while in college
and said he proposed to his now husband
uh chasen
in an airport terminal so
this is explaining because remember
repeat bootage was appointed the
secretary of transportation he is
as we talked about yesterday big news
here big deal he is the
um second gay cabinet official
in history he's the second huge huge
stuff
and probably the first one in the
transportation department
but now they're explaining you know why
he deserves to be
the head of the transportation
department and the reasons he deserves
it is because he loves
transportation he he rode on the amtrak
as a kid
and he proposed to his husband in an
airport terminal
now the washington post has come out in
defense
washington post democracy dies in
darkness and their whole
you know we can we can rely on them
to hold the powers that be accountable
and so their headline today was pete
budage is right
airports are romantic
this by the way not an op-ed this is not
in their opinion section
i think this was like in their lifestyle
section
airports are romantic
now many people are focusing on on this
idea that um
he's qualified to be the secretary of
transportation
because he proposed in an airport
terminal and
and uh and you know he wrote a train in
college people are focusing on that as
the dumbest thing
and that is very dumb you know that is
like me
going to uh apply to become the head
chef at a four-star restaurant
and you know i hand in my resume and
i've got listed qualification
um i enjoy eating
i had a birthday party at the macaroni
grill when i was in fifth grade
you know it's like that um
and that is very dumb and uh i think
that that deserves quite a bit of
mockery
but let's not let's let's please not
just skip over
personal love of transportation
what does that mean you love
transportation
oh you know i love transportation what
do you mean like you like to travel
no just transportation in general i love
it all look
cars bus scooter
rollerblades i'm just a big fan big fan
of i'm a big fan
of transporting through really any means
this is good i mean it is good i think
in fairness
it's good to have someone who is
pro-transportation heading
the transportation department there are
a lot of anti-transportation people out
there
that's a big thing you talk to people
all the time and they say no i'm really
i'm again and i you know personally i'm
against transportation i don't think
anyone should go anywhere ever
so um so maybe that's good maybe that's
all for the best
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second i did want
to address something real quick
um this is this is this is uh if you
follow me on twitter maybe
you've followed this controversy a
little bit but before we move on to the
next segment
i did want to address this because there
are many people speaking of
cancellations there are many people
attempting to cancel me this week
for a tweet that i that i sent out um
which i posted a couple days ago
and has provoked a very strong reaction
that is still not
still not gone away um i'm being called
a sexist and a misogynist and a bad
husband and a bad father for this
here's what i said i said as a father of
four kids i can say one thing that never
gets easier is changing dirty diapers
very disgusting i mean i've never done
it but it seems like it probably sucks
and this has caused many people
many you should see the emails i've
gotten to experience
real anger and hurt uh because they say
that this is
you know it's misogynistic it
perpetuates a stereotype and
i so what i want to do i don't often do
this but i wanted to apologize
um for this i do deserve to be canceled
and i just want to clarify that i didn't
mean anything offensive by it
all i meant all i meant
is that changing diapers is women's work
that's all i was saying um i didn't mean
if i'm sorry if i was misinterpreted
i didn't mean anything besides that
that's all i was trying to say
and i do admit that i have avoided at
all costs
the diaper changing task i have devised
many clever schemes
in order to accomplish this and the
first one which is really quite
brilliant
is uh whenever i smell a a diaper
whenever i smell a full diaper
i will say to the child hey you need a
new diaper
go find mommy go find mommy go find her
go find mommy i bet she has candy for
you go find her
and then they'll run off and they'll
find mommy and and then the next part of
the strategy is to go hide
so you know hide lock yourself in the
bathroom hide in the garage
go run an errand don't come back to the
coast is clear
yeah we develop these are survival
strategies we develop as parents
but um that's it i just wanted to
clarify that and i i'm sure that now i
have
um people who will feel better about it
and it's good that i was able to get
that off my chest
it's been a tumultuous year a lot of
uncertainty
and we know that's you deal with that
every year especially this year
and one thing about about about tumult
and
and uncertainty is that you want to
start thinking about your investments
and hedging your investments with
something
something stable something like gold and
you hear a lot about gold and how the
price of gold is skyrocketing and that
sounds great but the problem is it's
sort of a barrier to entry where you
feel like well i can't go out and just
buy gold i don't have the money for that
that's why acre is such a great company
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30 bucks a month
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house
so what this means is you can invest in
physical gold without having the money
to you know come out of pocket
all at once you can build up to it with
acre taking physical delivery of your
gold means it's safe and sound and in
your hands
acre designs their gold in california
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland
um and on top of that they've also got
if you feel like you want to
be a little bit more aggressive they've
got the recently introduced 100
per month subscription for their five
gram gold bar
whatever you want to do you know however
you want to approach this the fact is to
get to start investing in gold and maybe
that's a
new year's resolution i'm going to start
investing and you can start investing
with acre visit get
acre gold dot com walsh and start
investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar if you
want to qualify
for the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be the recipient and mention
at get underscore acre again that's
getacre gold.com
walsh and we want to thank akergold for
supporting the show
and um this is coming up in just a few
days monday december 21st the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw will
be available exclusively at the daily
wire
website dailywire.com originally
released as an audio podcast and it was
it was very successful
in audio form if you even if you if you
saw it in audio if you listen to an
audio form
i would recommend watching it it's even
better watching it if you never heard it
at all then you're really in for a treat
you can watch as well as listen on the
daily wire apple tv or roku app or at
dailywire.com
this of course is a dramatically
inspiring story apollo 11 what we saw
fantastic series to watch with your
loved ones over the holiday break and
right now you can get it for 20
off with code watch when you go to
dailywire.com
subscribe and become an insider or above
member
and finally one other thing on uh monday
november on monday december 21st
be sure to watch backstage at 7 pm
central time
to see all the daily wire hosts wrapping
up the year and uh i will actually
be there because i have emerged from my
cave
and i am the mid society again which
means i will i will be there for the
backstage and
uh it'll be good wrapping up what we may
call a very unique year so make sure you
tune in on monday for that
all right we're going to move on now to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel everyone
involved in this story the singer lizzo
has been in the midst of a pr crisis and
public backlash because
she drank a smoothie lizzo announced on
instagram that she had decided to go on
a juice cleanse
and this news provoked horror in outrage
among many people
in the quote fat community who felt that
she had betrayed them
lizzo is a smoothie drinking judas
selling out her fellow fat people
stabbing them in the back let's read
some of the reaction from people who are
extremely mentally stable i'm sure
this is one person blue checkmark on
twitter says lizzo
girl why it was inevitable the industry
is so violent towards fat women
of course she was going to submit to
toxic diet culture it was only a matter
of time
i think the disappointment lies in a lot
of us especially fat black women
seeing ourselves in a woman who was so
proud and confident in her body
it made us want to do it want to do the
same to ours
i have empathy for those who succumb to
the pressures of fat phobia
especially when you're in the public eye
especially when you exist within several
intersections that carry little
privilege
other reactions someone says fat phobia
intersects with other oppressions
if you're a feminist or an lgbtq plus
ally or stand with blm et cetera
you have to stand with fat folk too
someone else said
to see lizzo finally fall into the trap
of detox scams is so disheartening
she was the beacon for fat girls like me
a goal that
sorry i almost read that as bacon um i
did
almost read it but i didn't read it that
way uh a goal that showed
a goal that showed we could learn to
love ourselves and damn everyone else
and now she's not i feel so hurt
and then there was this yes i'm angry
yes i'm triggered
yes i am mourning a big b word uh that
she might want to get
skinny because that's one more battle
fat phobia has won
another lost to a system that wants me
dead
and then someone else accused lizzo of
promoting stuff that directly damages
our community that being the fat
community
now this all led to lizzo releasing a
statement on tick-tock explaining
why she went on a diet she wants to be
very clear that she in no way was trying
to lose weight
god forbid she would never try to avoid
heart disease and extend her life and
enjoy greater health and fitness by
losing weight
never that would be terrible so here's
here's how she explained her
suspicious smoothie consumption listen
i did the 10 day smoothie detox and as
you know i would
normally be so afraid and ashamed to
post
things like this online because i feel
like as a big girl people just
expect if you are doing something for
health you're doing it for like a
dramatic weight loss
and that is not the case um in reality
november stressed me the [ __ ] out i
drank a lot i ate a lot of spicy things
and things that
my stomach up and i wanted to reverse it
and get
back to where i was i'm so proud of
myself i'm proud of my results
um my sleep has improved my hydration
my inner peace my mental stability my
body my [ __ ] skin the whites my eyes
like
i feel and look like a bad [ __ ] and i
think like
that's it i'm a big girl who did a
smoothie detox
and i wanted to share that with you guys
i got exactly what i wanted out of it
and every big girl should do whatever
they want with their bodies
sorry i'm not buying it lizzo i'm not i
think you drank a smoothie
because you hate fat people i know
that's what that's what's in my mind
every time i go to smoothie king
in fact my favorite smoothie is called
the fat phobia
it comes with bananas strawberries
yogurt whey protein
and a little dash of body shaming just a
dash i want to overdo it
so there are a number of very dumb
things bubbling to the surface amid this
controversy the first and most obvious
of course is the idea that fat is an
identity that one should proudly embrace
let's be clear about this obesity is a
condition
not an identity it is a self-imposed
condition in most cases
being proud of obesity is really no
different from being proud of having
liver cirrhosis from drinking too much
alcohol
these are lethal conditions brought upon
by overconsumption
some people may be more susceptible to
liver diseases and so their alcohol
their their alcoholism causes major
problems whereas
somebody else can drink just as much and
have no problem that's unfortunate if
you're
the person more susceptible but it
doesn't change the fact that it was
avoidable it was brought on by your own
choices and it's bad it's unhealthy it's
deadly it's not good
the same goes for morbid obesity yes
there are different body types
yes some people are heavier than others
but morbid obesity is not one neutral
body type among others
it is something that happens from
massive overeating
a catastrophic lack of physical exercise
and again
it will kill you eventually so that's
one dumb thing
here's another the fat community
this is one of the hallmarks of our
modern age the cheapening of the concept
of community
everything's a community now your
physical characteristics put you in a
community
your sexual proclivities vices hobbies
everything
you know we would say now that a fat man
who enjoys star wars
and video games and let's say foot
fetishism
is in the fat community the star wars
community the gamer community and the
foot fetish community
but in what sense are any of these
actual communities the only thing you
have in common
is this one aspect of yourself an aspect
that is either unimportant in the grand
scheme or unhealthy or just kind of
weird
and yet this becomes a community see i
know what's meant when i talk about the
church community
if you have a church community these are
people who live near you
worship with you they have in common
with you the same the same values and
priorities at the deepest level
and you rely on each other for help
friendship comfort and support
it's a community but what does it mean
to have for a fat person to have a
community with other fat people
the only thing they have in common is
that they don't burn enough calories
relative to what they consume
how is this the foundation for any sort
of meaningful communal relationship
and the other problem with this commun
this communitization of everything
and yes communisation is a word
according to me and other members of the
making of words community
the other problem with it is that it has
the effect of of making people
comfortable
with aspects of themselves that they
should not be comfortable with
a person who struggles with a certain
vice say overeating
can go online search google and find
whole communities of people who are the
same way
and who aren't trying to get over it or
overcome it but are just living in it
proudly and then that person could say
oh well a lot of other people have this
problem too
it must not be a problem then
finally we have to focus on lizzo
herself for a moment the fact is
you know she did go on a juice cleanse
and that is something you do if you want
to lose weight
now she's backtracking and what might be
the weirdest backtrack in the history of
backtracking
but it's clear that she was trying to
get a hold of her weight
a little bit which is good but you find
this with a lot of celebrities
and and some of uh some of those people
complaining on twitter were right about
just this one part of it where so often
there are fat celebrities who go on
about embracing your body just as it is
even if you're fat and
then they go and slim down and lose the
weight
this isn't a betrayal obviously but it
is a weird sort of hypocrisy
hypocrisy in that it reveals that they
didn't really mean
everything they said about embracing
your body no matter its size and staying
positive about it
even if you're morbidly obese they
didn't believe it
and shouldn't believe it because it's
crazy except that now
rather than say to their audience hey
listen actually being extremely
overweight isn't good it's not healthy
you know i was able to get in healthier
shape and let me help you do the same
instead of that they say oh no being
extremely obese is still super great
i'm not fat anymore but you should
totally stay fat yourself
they encourage people to be unhealthy
even though they clearly know better
so the whole thing is crazy irrational
and highly cancelable
that's why everybody involved here is
canceled
lizzo the fat community all canceled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
the experts tell us we can't travel or
take off the masks
even after we get the vaccine british
scientists demand we postpone christmas
and aoc defends porn check it out on the
michael knowles show